Blast your mind.
Everything alright?
My name is Melinda.
People don't usually give me the chance to get to know me.
Hey. Diane left again without cleaning the bathrooms, already stalking.
That's okay, I'll do it.
Excuse me, Sir. It's against the rules
to smoke near a pump.
What is there? Do I take this and stick it in the pump?
I wasn't trying to be mean to you.
How are you in there? Everything good tonight?
Yeah, everything's good.
Melinda, what the hell are you doing?
You are so
creepy.
Okay, everything inside. Both the registers
and everything in the sink.
What's your plan?
You're not even supposed to be here.
It's too late.
Is there anyone else in here with you?
You gotta let me out of here. Ok, I'm not gonna hurt you.
I know you're lying to me.
The second I untie you I know you gonna kill me.
Why do you keep crying?
Is everything alright?
Yes. You keep asking me that and I keep telling you yes.
Let's get out of here while we still can together.
Blast your mind.
That's very possible.
I burn myself all the time.
It's not a bad thing.
Fire just forces things to change really fast.